they bought him stuff they bought him
stuff brian and that's what love is they
bought him a lot of stuff
i don't know if you know that but that's
what love is
nina what are some of voldemort's most
redeeming qualities
whoo
this was a tough question when you ask
me brian because it kind of feels like
when people say you know at least hitler
was a painter and liked dogs
um
it was kind of thin on the ground um
so i guess the
you know the biggest thing i kind of
came up with is if you know about his
his backstory it's very troubled and i
feel like
uh
this is mentioned a bit in the films but
the books definitely go more into it
where you know his mother
was a witch who tricked a handsome
muggle into marrying her and then
you know use love potion they had a
child he left her yeah and uh and so and
then the mother dies and so he's left at
an orphanage and then brought to
hogwarts later so there and you know
there is a a horrible
tragic quality to that whole story that
like he's born to people who do not love
each other outside of magical artifice
uh his mother does love him but dies
pretty quickly
so i mean there is a sympathetic oh god
it feels so gross to say that edge to
voldemort just say it let's say fine i'm
gonna own it there's a specific element
to his character he has inherent issues
across the board he's
he is also an orphan but he like but his
parents like at least harry's parents
really liked each other i don't think
voldemort's tolerated each other outside
of the fact that his mom was drugging
his dad on a regular basis i mean that's
just i mean that's typical these days i
mean that is the plot of phantom thread
sorry to spoil that film for anyone who
hasn't watched it so i guess you know
it's an important there's a lot of
crossover between the harry potter crowd
and the phantom thread crowd yeah
probably yeah i would think so but yeah
so i think that's the biggest kind of
thing i came up with is that
there is a very tragic sad element to
him and i think that needs to be
considered but also
does not excuse anything that he ever
does i need to be very clear about that
so for you the redeeming quality is that
he's got a
a back story that that a person can
relate to we all come from yeah our own
version of that it's not necessarily
that but like you know no one's
childhood is idyllic no one has a
has you know perfect parents no one has
a perfect family right so when you
consider his backstory you can start to
see
why he is the way he is he was a
lonely abandoned kid orphaned kid who
grew up with nothing and when you look
at another antagonist like draco malfoy
who grew up in a mansion with two loving
parents
really you know had every amount of
loving
like i loved him enough to like get his
hair done yeah they bought him stuff
they bought him stuff brian and that's
what love is they bought him a lot of
stuff
i don't know if you know that but that's
what love is so
so that kid had every element of
privilege and still just sucked so
you know
yeah there's a sympathetic uh element to
voldemort's entire backstory
and
yeah that's kind of all i've got about
the guy that's something yeah it's
terrific
i think you could have gotten him out on
parole
yeah i'll see if
he's up in 10 or 20 years
tom what about you what are some of
voldemort's most redeeming qualities
that you could think of
you know i was i was thinking about it
and i think that he is uh
aside from the the very important detail
of his being british i think that he is
the most american
villain
uh that you could ask for i think like
he's he's got this kind of an idealized
version of like reagan-era politics to
him where he picked himself up by his
bootstraps
lifted himself up off the ground he gets
done with school what does he do does he
dwell on the fact that yeah he kills
some kids he doesn't he like he goes out
there and after getting if i'm not
mistaken nina wasn't he was offered a
job in government right
he was offered a job uh
either at hogwarts or in the ministry
i'm not sure which and he takes a job at
a store
at a small business right supporting a
small business
and then he uses that to build himself
up further right like that's uh that's
where he learns about horcruxes and
stuff right no he knew about her oh no
no tom he knew about horcruxes before
that it's where he finds out where the
most valuable items are going so he can
make them into horcruxes that's even
better so he's got an eye for business
and then he starts his own small
business from the ground up
he uh he inspires love in his father
you're calling this the death eaters a
small business it's a cat i mean what is
it you have to give it it's good brand
terrific
what income do they make
i don't know
friendship is the the greatest treasure
of all that's a great point ryan uh
whatever they finds they keeps
and you're right you know like if they
had spelled death eaters wrong and like
as one word it would have been a great
like app startup uh
no i think so i think that there are a
lot of good qualities the guy i think uh
he's economical
in the uh you know there's that old
what's that journalistic phrase like you
never use a five-cent word or never use
a 10-cent word when the five cent word
will do and he kind of brings that to
his face where he like uh
he doesn't need the hair like what's the
nose doing for it let's lose it like
lazy
lose it it's just resistance
yeah there's another well truism like a
design is not perfect when there's
nothing left to add but rather when
there's nothing left to take away and
that's what he did with the front of his
head
that he's persistent and that's a good
quality because every single year he
tries to kill a teenager
actually i have one more he's
considerate because when he tries to
kill that teenager every year he does it
right after the school year is ending or
when it's about to end he is very
considerate of harry's schedule he makes
sure they get through finals yeah yeah
yeah he wants to make sure the kids get
their learning done first
he's got like the summer blahs at the
beginning of the year let's get past
that like really find himself
redefining
and i just think that's admirable
well who wants to start a magic war in
the middle of winter like we're all
trailed down
yeah it's so grey outside you want to
make sure that the days are as long as
possible
absolutely get that sunshine
get that vitamin d everybody's if
there's one thing he's known for it's
for soaking up those rays yeah he's got
something
such a sun bunny
[Laughter]
he put out that surf album that was
pretty great like right now
beach boy covers yeah
yeah
it's really good he probably saved a lot
of money by like rooming with uh
professor quarle in the first book by
like just living on the back of his head
the guy's got
he's that was mine actually that was
similar to mine because i was gonna say
he's so
he's he's single-minded he's dedicated
this is a guy who is committed
so committed that he'll do anything he
needs to do to achieve his goals
including
sticking himself on the back of
someone's head that is also wrapped up
in a tight turban so he's not getting
any well the no the turban is is uh
specifically to hide him though like
that's what i'm saying like yeah that's
what i'm saying like that's how into
he's like he's like whatever just stick
me on the back of your head wear a
turban like it's the only way that this
will work i don't think i can't breathe
the conversation went he just like
walked up to the sky and he was like hey
stick me on the back of your head and
the guy went absolutely guys i gotta i
gotta stop you right here there's okay a
couple of things first of all the
turbine was not the only option uh let
me just give the photoshop to him some
headaches here uh he could have worn a
bank a backwards baseball cap uh that
would have looked
pretty fly i think you'll agree uh and
secondly brian i don't think you get to
call somebody single-minded if they're
literally living on somebody else's
brain
okay fair enough fair point that's true
and another hat option to celebrate the
second season of the greatest show of
all time is that he could have worn a
fedora with a safari brim down the back
like tim robinson and i think you should
leave
everyone loved that hat
he's carrying around dice and his robes
yeah it would be a great look for him
i like it
so brian yours is his persistence and
his i just was gonna say like this is a
guy who'll do
who'll do what it takes and if if that
means making it so that he can't breathe
and all he can smell is
some guy's head at all times at all
hours
like how does you know does he eat does
he like does quarrel like
put the soup spoon behind him oh i know
he's just like that does he like just
let like rats crawl up his back so that
he can munch on him or something i don't
know how to crawl up there probably
well that henchman is a rat they do
something else i think that scene would
have been so great in the movies like
you get to see him at the great hall at
dinner yeah he's like sneaking a straw
up into the back of this he's pushing a
chicken nugget
a drumstick a full drumstick and he's
just like scratching the back of his
head with it pulls out a bone and he's
like oh that's weird oh magic magic
yeah and nobody thinks it's weird
because magic yeah you can get away with
a lot at hogwarts because magic because
magic yeah yeah so yeah that's my pick i
think you know if you want something
done he may not actually get it done but
he will do everything he can to try
you bet he will short of trimming his
nails
short of trimming his nose i mean that's
a bridge too far i agree with you that
he is single-minded brian but i do want
to push back against that he'll do
whatever it takes because if you think
about the plan he comes up with in
goblet of fire his whole plan is
have a henchman sneak into hogwarts
harry has to live through all of these
super dangerous tasks he cannot die
during any of them or the whole plan is
ruined okay
and no one else can win the tournament
and he's this is like a nine to ten
month
gambit
where literally everything could go
wrong at every second just for a vial of
blood he could have just been like hey
rat henchman go bite him in his sleep
and put it in a vial and come back i
mean they could have killed him dozens
of times yeah
voldemort is very it's very like dr evil
vibes where he like lowers them over
like a
pool of sharks with leisure
like how will you get out of this yeah
that voldemort does have that vibe a
little bit but a goblin is kind of the
worst example to me because i'm like
this is a full year's worth of
nonsense that could all go very very
very wrong and yet
this is your grand plan there were
definitely easier ways to do this he's
from the mouse trap school of plans
okay now he needs to make sure he needs
to make sure that you know you know the
boot has to kick it in just the right
way you have to get the gear has to be
just in place
yeah it's so scary once this man dives
into a small cup of
water i think you're fine
i love this
you know what else you know what we
forgot to talk about he seems like he's
a great hugger
you remember uh when he gives you a hug
with malphite
last for an hour yeah that's a that's a
firm hug yeah
he uh he really owns the bald look uh
he's always like running his hands over
his head he clearly really takes them
the magic world yeah yeah oh that's a
disturbingly apt comparison yeah
and he looks a little bit like ray fines
just a little chance i don't see it
no
he kind of looks like the guy from made
manhattan but not really
not much
thanks for watching please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single
video